aquí escribí algunas algunos ejemplos de
relaciones entre dos variables en este
caso tenemos m y n a y b xy y quiero a
ver si podemos identificar si las
relaciones son directas es decir si
varían directamente o varían
inversamente o tal vez ninguna de las
dos
así que iniciemos con esto aquí tengo yo
m sobre en es igual a 1 sobre 7 vamos a
manipular esto si multiplicamos ambos
lados por n que obtenemos lo que tú
quieres en general hacer es separar las
variables que una te queda de un lado y
la otra del otro para ver a qué forma
llegas si a la forma m es igual acá por
n eso sería variación directa oa la
forma m igual acá por 1 sobre n
eso es variación inversa cuál de estas
dos variaciones será así que tenemos
esta primera relación vamos a
multiplicar ambos lados de la relación o
de la ecuación por n y tenemos entonces
que me es igual estos dos se cancelan m
es igual a 1 sobre 7 por n
es ver que tiene la misma forma de la
variación directa cierto estamos aquí m
es igual a una constante multiplicada
por n así que esto es variación directa
están variando directamente es variación
directa ahora vamos con la siguiente a
por b es igual a menos 3 aquí podemos
dividir entre o entre b no importa pero
vamos a dividir entre a así que a por b
entre a es igual a menos 3 entre a se
cancelan las así nos queda veces igual a
menos 3 entre a y eso es lo mismo que ve
igual a menos 3 por 1 sobre a esto tiene
la misma forma que esta variación la
variación inversa cierto aquí el menos 3
es la constante scan así que esto es
variación inversa variación inversa
ahora vamos con la siguiente tenemos x x
y es igual a 1 sobre 10 aquí otra vez
vamos a separar las variables entonces
voy a dividir entre alguna de las dos ya
sea entre x o entre
x porque solo hay que dividir entre
alguna de las dos entonces aquí dividido
entre x aquí se cancelan las x nos queda
y es igual a 1 sobre 10 sobre x lo cual
es lo mismo que 1 sobre 10 x y esto es
igual a 1 sobre 10 x 1 sobre x esto es
la constante esto es que ha multiplicado
por 1 sobre x así que esto es esto es
variación inversa ahora vamos con la
siguiente bueno de hecho ya está esa
está ya está es un regalo de el regalo
del día porque ve aquí tenemos
simplemente hay que voltear la igualdad
ponemos entonces a n ajá ok n es igual a
9 por 1 sobre m y ya tiene la forma de
variación inversa y tenemos la constante
9 multiplicado a a 1 sobre m ajá
entonces tienen la forma de variación
inversa hay también recuerda a quien
está variando inversamente con m lo cual
es lo mismo que m varía inversamente con
n son
equivalentes ahora vamos con este
tenemos es igual a un tercio menos a y
aquí hay un truco cierto aquí no está
muy claro tenemos aquí una constante y
de hecho ya están las variables
separadas pero tenemos ahí un signo
menos en si no sabemos si es a variación
variación directa o variación inversa y
de hecho o sorpresa es ninguna de las
dos no es ni variación directa ni
variación inversa entonces ok variación
directa si si la variable x aquí tenemos
xy entonces si la variable x se
incrementa en su escala digamos por 2 de
1 a 2
también la variable ya incrementaría en
la misma escala o mejor voy a poner a mn
porque son las que voy a usar para este
ejemplo entonces digamos si bien es
igual a tenemos m es igual a 1 sobre 7
por n si es igual
entonces m es igual a 1 sobre 7 ajá
ahora cuando en es igual a 7 m es igual
a 1 y puedes ver que que n crece en
escala de 7 si eso pasa también m está
creciendo en una escala de 7 cierto lo
podemos ver aquí en la tabla entonces
están variando directamente cuando m
crece n crece cuando n crece m crece así
que esto esto es variación directa esto
es variación directa ahora vamos con
este otro ejemplo de variación inversa
entonces voy a poner las variables en la
tabla tenemos tenemos ahí b cuando a es
igual a 1 podemos ver que es igual a
menos 3 cierto simplemente vamos a poner
aquí uno sobre uno se canse y nos queda
es igual a menos 3 sobre 1 es igual a
menos 3 ahora cuando es igual
a tres cuando multiplicamos esto por
tres entonces qué pasa vamos a obtener
de igual a menos uno cierto ahora nota
que aquí yo no estoy multiplicando por
tres estoy dividiendo entre tres o lo
que es lo mismo estoy multiplicando
estoy multiplicando pero por el inverso
de tres por uno sobre tres así que si yo
aquí estoy incrementando la escala de
uno a tres de la vb ésta está
decreciendo cierto en este otro caso de
ninguno verás que ninguno de los dos se
cumplen y el directo ni el inverso
así que ok amén este otro tenemos aquí
hay b cuando es igual a 1 veamos qué
sucede cuando es igual a 1 tenemos un
tercio menos 1 eso sería igual a menos
dos tercios
y ok si aquí dividimos entre 3 sólo por
diversión tendríamos entonces tendríamos
entonces igual a un tercio o es lo mismo
que multiplicar por un tercio entonces
si a es igual a un tercio es igual a
cero y aquí no está algo extraño si esto
fuera una varias si esto fuera variación
directa estaríamos multiplicando por un
tercio lo cual no hicimos y si fuera
variación inversa
estaríamos multiplicando por tres lo
cual tampoco pasó entonces
aquí los factores no alteraron en
realidad esto cierto esto simplemente
fue una traslación de dos tercios las
variables en esta último las variables
en este último ejemplo no están variando
ni inversamente ni directamente